after being in the hospital for 95 days
Broadway star Nick Cordero passed away
at the age of 41 from kolben 19 he was
born in Hamilton Ontario Canada and
after attending Ryerson University he
made the leap to the Big Apple and saw a
huge success on Broadway he was
nominated for a Tony Award for his work
in bullets over Broadway in 2014
yes he was admitted to the hospital on
March 30th and suffered several
complications due to Cova nineteen
including strokes and blood clots which
led to a leg amputation his wife Amanda
gave regular updates on social media on
his progress and his fight but she
posted yesterday God is another angel in
heaven now my darling husband passed
away this morning who surrounded and
loved by his family singing and praying
as he gently left this earth I cannot
begin to thank everyone enough for the
outpour of love and support and help we
received these last 95 days you have no
idea how much you've lifted my spirits
at 3 p.m. every day as the world saying
mixed song live your life we sing it to
him today holding his hands as I sang
the last line to him they'll give you
hell but don't you light then don't you
let them kill your light not without a
fight live your life a smile because you
definitely put up a fight I will love
you forever and always my sweet man the
outpouring has been huge from lots of
celebrities including Viola Davis who
wrote rest in peace Nik Darrow my
condolences to you Amanda who fought and
loved so hard so sorry for his little
went ha my heart is with you may fights
of angels lin-manuel miranda tweeted
devastating what a loss what a light
whole heart with Amanda and his family
tonight Kate Hudson Kate Hudson
commented on Amanda's post saying so sad
to hear this news sending so much love
and light and Sarah Paulsen wrote Oh
Amanda I am so deeply sorry for your
devastating and profound loss sending
you strength love and prayers how lucky
he was to have you by his side in every
way if you need anything and I mean
anything please do not have
you have an army of people with open
arms ready and willing to do anything
and everything zach braff who was best
friends with Nick wrote on Instagram
I've honestly never known a kind of
person but kovat doesn't care about the
purity of your soul of the goodness in
your heart the last thing he ever texted
me was to look out for his wife and
one-year-old son Elvis I promised the
world they will never want for anything
I feel so incredibly grateful I got to
have Nick Cordero enter my life and
Simone says really thought you would
pull through because I know this was
such a long struggle for him like 95
days in the hospital and just yeah all
those complications but yeah there were
ups and downs that Amanda was reporting
that you know he'd he'd wake up and then
you think he was turning the corner but
yeah unfortunately he lost his life yeah
we are thought so with the family with
his son I just I can't even imagine he's
41 95 days as you mentioned and Zach
just tweeted out also wear a mask he's
talking about taking the step border to
understand right now that as we go
through the different phases in our
country in Canada and just making sure
you continue knowing that there's a
pandemic to protect yourself or to
others and so he's taking that message
forward with everything that happened
with Nick so I mean it's a huge loss he
was still massive in Broadway and just
you think about how young he is he's my
age so it's you know it's I'm really
stopping right now yeah yeah he was so
incredibly talented and kovat doesn't
discriminate it doesn't matter you know
who you are it can happen to any of us
so we definitely have to take it
seriously I'm sure it's very frustrating
for his family to even see some of these
masks on mask off debates that are going
on but you know what really hurts me is
that his wife is left behind and with
the one-year-old son you know having a
one-year-old in general is so hard it's
so tasking to have to go through this
grief that is so profound
especially in quarantine especially with
the state of the world I mean there's a
lot going on right now for one woman so
you know
cover her in prayer I'm happy that
people are you know doing an outpouring
for her and showing love and support and
I hope people who loved Nick will honor
him by wearing a mask and respecting
this yeah yeah something says so
freaking sad afro says so sad he fought
so hard hope he was at peace now and I
was gonna say I hope this is a lesson
that people you know that don't think
the young are vulnerable in any kind of
way but I mean how many lessons do
people need that this is that this is
hitting everyone I mean yeah America you
have 130,000 people are dead now and
yeah there's there's tons of these
stories it's not just seniors that are
dying I mean Nick was a healthy healthy
guy there's been tons of people like
that so I don't know what it's gonna
take for some people to get the message
across you know we're seeing videos like
I saw videos Fire Island this weekend
and I think was the Ozarks as well like
there's still these videos and I think
was in Boston as well it's the least
huge parties and no one's wearing a mask
and I don't get what it's gonna take to
get it through someone's people's minds
that even if you don't die from it I
mean they don't know the long-term
effects of you either like they're kind
of discovering now that it does damage
your your lungs during when you have it
but it's they're starting to see that it
has long-term effects on your lung
capacity like you mean it's not
something it's not a casual thing to do
so just put on the mask guys so yeah you
hope that yeah thanks passing if there's
any kind of yeah like lesson to be
learned it's just yet take this
seriously guys for the people that still
aren't taking it seriously yeah it's
true my friends aunt passed away of
colvett as well she was older my
husband's in medicine so I hear the
conversations of what's happening in
hospitals and it's great to know the
numbers are dropping in Ontario but the
importance of taking care of yourself in
your family I was just telling Keisha my
parents I have been seeing them through
a window because it's just a controlled
ER and it's been three and a half months
and I finally saw them from two meters
away and I haven't hugged them in a
while and it's hard it's really hard for
people not to be able to connect with
their family and friends but a write an
an again and I totally understand it but
at a time like this it's so important to
protect them and protect yourselves as
well hand-washing all of it wearing a
mask all these steps are they're put in
place especially Canada has done a
really great job of following those
rules no one is
questioning not wearing the mask it's
just making sure you actually wear the
mask I mean I was out and about on
Sunday and people are not wearing their
masks I was in a store and people were
not wearing their masks cuz it's it
should be mandatory it's something that
should just be part of your your world
at this point in the summer and we got
to fight this together it's just it just
really sad that we're reporting a story
about Nick dying after 95 days and
hopefully we don't have to do it more
and going in the future we just it's
just it's just not right that we can
actually take control of it and we
should yeah our survival instincts just
need to kick in you know as easily and
we've all had the cold we've all had the
flu
a lot of us don't know how we get it we
don't a lot of us are like how did I get
the cold when did this happen I mean
it's that easy to get that and it's that
common there has to be an understanding
that kovat it you can get covert very
easily as well if you're not careful
there just needs to be that type of
respect for it especially when we're
losing incredible talent like Nick
movers something like this that is that
is avoidable though we can we can
actually work on so I'm with you guys
it's a trying time and actually I had a
friend who went to a funeral for a loved
one that passed away in March and a week
or two later three of his family members
who went up to the podium to speak at
the funeral ended up dying from kovat
and it wasn't just based on the podium
the mic the way that it was ventilated
they got kovin and they and they died so
he has four family members that are gone
because of this and it happened in a
blink of an eye and a lot of people
there aren't social distancing I'm
seeing it they saw it over the holidays
as well so it's time to take it
seriously guys I mean I don't know much
more you can ask for at this point but
let's get it together
right